at the center of the ukraine crisis is
the man who initiated it russian
president vladimir putin when asked
yesterday what his country's next move
is he said it's quote according to the
plan holly williams is in key where
ukrainians are anxious to know what that
means holly good morning
good morning president biden also
addressed the russian people directly
yesterday saying quote you are not our
enemy and i do not believe you want a
bloody destructive war against ukraine
but now all eyes are on russia's
president vladimir putin and what he
decides to do next
russia released this video claiming it
shows some of its troops pulling back
from ukraine's border but even if it can
be verified massive russian military
drills are ongoing in belarus
on ukraine's northern border
and on the black sea just to the south
here in ukraine there's no sigh of
relief instead cyber attacks on two
banks and the defense ministry the
ukrainian authorities have stopped short
of blaming them outright on russia
i have my emergency bag
in my
flat and i'm ready
to defend my country it's two different
countries and they must understand that
it's two different countries
if vladimir putin really has decided
against an invasion it could be because
the u.s and its allies have made the
cost too high supplying weapons to
ukraine
and threatening putin with unprecedented
sanctions hitting his inner circle and
their family members vladimir putin is a
human rights violator and a kleptocrat
and a very rich man
bill browder was once one of the biggest
foreign investors in russia but then he
started campaigning against russian
corruption he told us putin's been
treated too softly in the past sending a
dangerous message he invaded georgia
he took crimea he bombed
civilians and hospitals in syria
he cheated in the olympics from his
standpoint he's gotten away with
everything
and
unless
we can actually prove to him that we're
serious he'll think he can get away with
it again
belarus claims all russian forces will
leave its territory once those military
exercises end this weekend we'll see if
that happens and yesterday russia again
dismissed fears of an invasion as quote
western war propaganda nate
we'll have more on this later in the
show holly williams in ukraine thank you